à l'aide de gaz lacrymogènes les membres
des forces de sécurité repousse sans
ménagement les protestataires venus les
défier ces affrontements se déroulent
quelques heures après une fusillade
entre troupes gouvernementales et
insurgés présumés
ces scènes de guérilla sont pourtant
rares à srinagar la principale ville du
cachemire indien
cette dernière est généralement épargnée
par les combats qui éclatent
régulièrement dans le reste de la région
entre indépendantistes et militaires la
tension s'est encore accentuée l'année
dernière avec la décision du
gouvernement de narp hendra maudit de
révoquer le statut d'autonomie du
territoire celui ci est désormais placée
sous haute surveillance par new delhi
[Musique]
le jammu et cachemire est le ladakh
peuvent être une source d'inspiration
pour la prospérité et la paix de l'inde
[Musique]
ces régions peuvent grandement
contribuer au développement de l'inde
nous devrions tous faire un effort pour
restaurer leurs vieux jours de gloire
le nouvel arrangement et résulte de ces
efforts et cela fonctionnera directement
dans l'intérêt des citoyens
le conflit au cachemire est aussi
complexifier par la confrontation entre
armée indienne et pakistanaise islamabad
revendiquent ce territoire depuis la
partition avec l'inde en 1947 et depuis
plusieurs mois des accrochages ont lieu
presque quotidiennement à la frontière
entre les deux pays pour le pakistan le
gouvernement indien aux primes la
population locale à majorité musulmane
c'est une situation épouvantable en
matière des droits de l'homme avec des
violations commises en toute impunité
par l'inde
cela ne prendra fin que lorsque justice
sera faite au peuple du jammu et
cachemire à ces incidents s'ajoutent
aussi des confrontations entre
militaires indiens et chinois en août
plusieurs soldats ont été tués le long
de la frontière contestée par les deux
pays depuis le début de l'année plus de
300 personnes ont péri dans des
affrontements au cachemire indien